NARRATOR: It's San Francisco
in the 1970's, and it's the era
of peace, love, and low-riders.
Our story starts
here, in the Mission
of corner of 24th and Folsom.
This is Phil.
He will go on to become
the king of coffee.
PHIL JABER: Who's next?
NARRATOR: But more
on that later.
For now, he sells the
country's cheapest milk, beer,
and cigarettes.
PHIL JABER: I have
a mini-supermarket.
There's nothing I don't sell.
NARRATOR: This is Jacob,
Phil's number one employee.
JACOB JABER: Let me
know when you're ready.
Now?
OK.
NARRATOR: Not wanting to leave
a legacy of a liquor store
behind, Phil set his
sights on something bigger.
PHIL JABER: My friend's
coffee came to my dream,
and I'm taking it to the moon.
God bless.
NARRATOR: He set
out on a mission
to create the best
product possible.
Phil visited thousands of stores
and consumed gallons of coffee.
PHIL JABER: When I was
working with beans,
it's like a pharmacy.
We used to count them, one,
two, three, four, five.
We'd do this [INAUDIBLE].
Then I add another
culture of coffee to it.
No, add another.
No.
I spent days and hours.
NARRATOR: Meet Tesora,
Phil's first blend.
She took seven years to perfect.
PHIL JABER: Seven years.
[INAUDIBLE] that corner.
[INAUDIBLE] Seven
years, one blend.
Because I want to do it right.
NARRATOR: Tesora
was so good, Phil
experimented with more flavors.
There was something
for everybody.
And cup by cup, Philz
Coffee was born.
SPEAKER 1: My favorite flavor?
Um--
SPEAKER 2: That's
tough, I don't know.
My favorite drink--
SPEAKER 1: So Jacob's
Wonderbar was the first coffee
I ever had at Philz.
SPEAKER 3: The Philharmonic.
SPEAKER 4: Organic Peru Light.
SPEAKER 5: The Dancing Water.
SPEAKER 6: Philtered Soul.
SPEAKER 7: What's the flavor
profile of an ambrosia?
SPEAKER 8: Aromatic Arabic.
SPEAKER 9: Mint Mojito with an
extra shot of deliciousness.
SPEAKER 10: Pan
Galactic Gargle Blaster.
SPEAKER 11: Uh, hot chocolate?
PHIL JABER: And when I used to
sit in the coffee shop and sit,
people stiffs.
Don't talk.
They sitting in their
table like a plant.
I said that's not what I want.
I want to put a big community
table, put'em together.
I'm going to go say hi George,
how are you, this is Nancy.
Nancy, this is George.
And that's what I did.
SPEAKER 12: Coffee
is something that's
supposed to brighten your day.
And wake you up in the morning.
Inspire a conversation.
PHIL JABER: And
like I tell you, all
my coffee shop says you
go visit your grandma,
it's the best
thing you ever had.
SPEAKER 13: I wrote
a book at Philz.
And it's about Philz.
(IN UNISON) We got
engaged at Philz.
SPEAKER 14: We started
our business at Philz.
SPEAKER 15: I like Philz
so much, I got a tattoo.
SPEAKER 16: (SINGING)
Philz Coffee, ooh, coffee.
JACOB JABER: We believe to
deliver the best experience,
you have to be able
to be yourself.
SPEAKER 17: I get
to serve someone
a great cup of coffee
every day, and I
get to better someone's day.
SPEAKER 18: Why coffee?
Why not coffee?
Coffee is great.
SPEAKER 19: What we
do is so special.
And what we want to do is
share the special experience
with more people
around the world.
Our vision is to reinvent
the coffee experience.
We want to change the
way people drink coffee.
PHIL JABER: Which one
are we going to do now?
We're going to make
it with real love.
PHIL JABER: I believe I
was born to make coffee.
Just like people
born to be a doctor.
Frank Sinatra, born to sing.
I was born to make coffee.
JACOB JABER: My dad and I
started Philz Coffee in 2003
in San Francisco.
And now we have 11 locations.
And we're voted one of the
best coffee shops in the US.
PHIL JABER: I do this
just to see the color.
Not for any other reason.
JACOB JABER: He believed
in making coffee
without using machinery.
Everything is handcrafted,
one cup at a time.
PHIL JABER: I know
so much about beans.
I didn't know nothing.
JACOB JABER: There's
so many little things
that need to be perfect that add
up to something really great.
Google Apps plays a
role in that by making
our lives easier for email,
for chat, for documents.
It took us about 25 to 35
minutes from start to finish,
literally, to set everybody up.
We created a new
store check list.
We share a spreadsheet with
all of the people involved.
And it's helping us opening
stores more efficiently.
I know that it's
going to support us
not with just 10
stories, or 11 stores,
but a couple of thousand
stores down the road.
My dad never uses technology,
but he actually enjoys it
and says it's
really easy to use.
He said look, I
got an email today.
Our mission is to
better people's day.
We want them to walk out
of our store happier,
with a damn good cup of
coffee, and a feeling of wow,
they really cared about
me and my experience.
PHIL JABER: People, when
they like something,
they take you to the moon.
One day, I'm going to
do coffee in the moon.
PRESENTER 1: Phil
of Philz Coffee
immigrated to Alameda with his
family at a very young age.
He became passionate
about coffee as a child.
And soon, saw the business
potential grow over the years.
When he opened a grocery and
liquor store in the Mission,
he loved coffee so much that
he worked on coffee research
in his spare time.
With a passion for
people and coffee,
he spent 25 years perfecting
a variety of coffee blends.
In pursuing his dreams, Phil
converted his Mission store
to the first Philz
Coffee location in 2003.
Now at 30 locations in
California and Washington DC,
Phil attributes his success
to having a unique approach
to business, respect, and
faith in loving what you do.
Round of applause for Bill.
[APPLAUSE]
PRESENTER 1: All right.
Next up we have
Carolyn Frey, who
serves as Philz Coffee's
Chief People Officer,
overseeing recruiting, training,
HR, and their west coast
stores.
Prior to Philz, Carolyn
was a managing director
at the Corporate Executive
Board, otherwise known as CEB,
for 15 years.
Over her career there, she
led account management teams,
managed the firm's
largest client
accounts, and relocated
to San Francisco
to open and lead the first
office outside of DC.
She was the general
manager of the west coast
market in the San Francisco
office for the last seven
years.
CEB is a leading provider
of research, base guidance,
and human capital analytics
to Fortune 500 companies
and beyond.
Carolyn received many awards
during her time at CEB,
most notably a company
wide award for stewardship
of exceptional talent out of
4,500 employees, a top coach
award, and a company wide
award for innovation.
Round of applause, please.
And then last but
not least, we have
Faith Songco, who is the
dean of Philz University.
With a small team of designers,
trainers, and communicators,
they help define
the Philz culture
through learning experiences.
Prior to Philz, Faith
graduated from Cal Poly
in business administration
and child development.
She's worked for a nonprofit
called the Lindsey Meyer Teen
Institute, and the public
sector, more specifically
the California Judicial Branch
during Arnold Schwarzenegger's
term.
While this would have fulfilled
her aspirations to be Leslie
Knope, her career actually--
[LAUGHTER]
FAITH SONGCO: It's true.
PRESENTER 1: --actually led
her to 10 years at Apple,
building really cool
things for their people
in benefits, communications,
retail training,
and is one of the first
members of Apple University.
Round of applause
for Faith, please.
[APPLAUSE]
So with that, I'll hand
it off to the Philz team.
PHIL JABER: I want to thank
you all kindly for being here.
And I want to thank Google for
having us, Philz Coffee Bean
here.
Seems like Philz Coffee and
Google and high-tech companies,
we compliment each other.
As I look around, I see smart
people, intelligent men,
women with a smile.
Look at that.
How can I go wrong
not being here?
So I want to tell you
something about here.
We came, as you see in
the video, we came young.
My family been
here since 1920's.
When I was a little kid,
I always loved coffee.
In the old days, my
grandma, the neighbors,
they used to get
together and sit for two,
three hours, socialize.
And the only thing they
had was coffee or tea.
They didn't have
tequila or iPhone.
[LAUGHTER]
So I used to see them
talk for two, three hours.
Grandma or mom or
somebody go make coffee,
they never left the oven.
They work on the coffee.
It's not put it in the machine,
and push and a shot of espresso
come out.
And from there they make latte,
cappuccino, these fancy names.
So coffee is hand-crafted.
That I learned when I was a kid.
So I always like it
because in the old days,
people used to get
together, seal a deal,
talk, communicate
over a cup of coffee.
So I always like coffee.
So when I came to
the United States,
my family had a supermarket.
Then I went to
Alameda High School.
As I graduate, we
have summer vacation.
Then the second--
two, three months,
we went to college to register.
Second day, I get up, I said
I don't want to go to college.
Open store for me.
So I open the shop
on 24th Street.
I used to sell every item that
a household use in their homes.
And sell it at a
reasonable price.
I wasn't looking-- I
want to make 30%, 40%.
I want to make 3% to 5%.
But I want to rotate products.
Let's say, for example, I
buy $10,000 worth of milk.
I want to rotate that at
least four times a month.
So I'm spending $40,000 at 5%.
Well a month later,
I'm making 60%.
So that's how I
used to do business.
Milk, cigarette, liquor,
beer, coffee, deli.
There's nothing I don't sell.
In the meantime, I used to work
on my coffee, the handcrafted.
Because I want to be different
than any coffee shops.
They're all good.
God bless them all.
There's business for everybody.
But I want to capture the
quality of our new society.
You guys, the new society.
You guys smart, intelligent.
You guys have class,
you have taste.
You don't like BS.
You love quality.
You walk to it, you drive
to it, you even fly to it.
And you guys have money.
So I figure I'm going
to open a coffee shop.
And I visit over 1,100
coffee shops in 2002
to see why people go there,
what they're looking for,
what their expectation.
Is their employees happy?
Does the owner come there?
So some shops, I repeat, repeat.
Then I stopped.
So I wrote my own notes.
Because each one of them have
something good about them.
So I took one word from
here, one word from here.
But I wrote my own
concept, how I'm
going to run my coffee shops.
First and foremost
is hospitality.
That I see that
need that attention
and be sincere action.
Be loyal, be straight,
reasonable price,
quality products, which
is-- I conquer it.
25 years, I worked at it.
So I'm not worry about
the coffee concept.
Now I need to capture
the quality clientele
that no other
businesses can capture.
By hospitality, sincere
action, treat them
like you want to be treated.
You greet them from the first
18 seconds as they walk in.
And that's what happened to us.
We did a good job.
We used to have one
shop, me and my son.
Now we have over 37 shops.
We have a lot of
markets, quality
that we serve, like Whole Foods,
Mollie Stone, Williams-Sonoma,
[INAUDIBLE], Virgin America
airlines, the Facebook
headquarters, and all the
other high tech companies.
Google was my first one, to
sell coffee from Middlefield.
So these quality companies
and quality people, they
give me a name, a reputation.
Because our sincere action, I
have people who work for me,
they are team members, family.
One guy asked me, sir, for
how many employees you have?
I said I don't know what
you're talking about.
I don't have employees.
[PHONE RINGING]
I have--
[LAUGHTER] I'm sorry,
I should [INAUDIBLE]
PRESENTER 1: He has employees
and fans calling night and day.
It's his wife.
[LAUGHTER]
PHIL JABER: I don't
call her wife,
I call her my
bride for 36 years.
So I told him I didn't have
employees, I have families.
I have almost 800-1,000
families working for me.
And the guy was a business
major from Harvard.
He goes Jesus, I'd
never heard that before.
I visit a lot of high tech
companies, a lot of companies.
And they say I have
40,000 employees.
You're the only one who said
you have almost 1,000 families.
You impress me,
that's really great.
I said that's what we have, we
have families working for us.
And the quality of my clientele.
The first day they are
customers, the second day
they become clientele.
You guys-- my team
and my clientele
give us a name, a reputation.
That only happens
once in a lifetime.
We don't have money to buy it.
We earn it.
From you guys, by the people.
And you all put me
in the cloud now.
[LAUGHTER]
I remember the
clouds used to rain.
[LAUGHTER]
So when I wrote my concept,
before we start opening,
we have no money to open.
We have a journey,
agenda, we have a dream
that I'm going to conquer.
And it's not about talking.
The more people you
have who you talk to,
they take you away
from your concept.
So I used to discuss
things with my son.
Which is-- he's my
oxygen, my best friend.
We have lots of respect.
And we used to talk about
things, write things down.
And we used to action
the second day.
With so little money
I had, I let it be.
Because that's how I learned
it was going to work or not.
By-- see, I want to
tell you something.
In the business world, without
money, you can't do nothing.
So if you keep it in the
back or under the mattress,
it ain't going to do nothing.
It's dead meat.
So I used my money work for me.
So we grew.
And I just can't tell
you how good it is.
I could talk for 10 years.
What happened to us only
happened once in a lifetime.
It's how you conduct,
how you present yourself.
The hospital and the
quality of the products.
And like I said, you all
have class and taste.
So you guys taking
me to the moon.
There's a lot to say.
But you must have something
before you start company.
Don't open company, have
money, and from there, you
start to learn and
getting better, better.
We were better from the
first day we opened.
Because we know
what we need to do.
And we action people.
And we have never been shy.
I loved people when I was a kid.
I feel I'm the
most wealthiest man
in this planet by how many
people like me, respect me,
trust me.
Because three things we never
did, [? attack ?] my parents,
cheat, steal, or lie.
We never do that.
We not tried to say sorry or
I'm sorry, I don't have it.
But we have the morals,
the basics, the value.
Money is the last
thing in my life.
I'm into health before wealth.
My father wrote me a note, 1976.
Says let the life I
live speaks for me.
So I realize that after he
passed away in '87, when
we were going to the cemetery
and so many cars behind,
he has so much respect
from his community,
his family, his friends.
That's when I learned let
the lives speaks for you.
That means a lot.
So that's my mission in
life, business, families,
work, talking to you guys.
I want to learn from you all,
you all have something good
about yourself.
You should all adore yourselves.
Never underestimate yourself.
Because we all go-- and the key
in life is-- God bless America.
America has every culture
you think of in this planet.
So I have a blend.
If you look in my
charts, my menu
says [INAUDIBLE], Jacob
Wonderbar, Ambrosia.
It doesn't say espresso,
double shot, latte, cappuccino.
You go everywhere,
latte, espresso, shot.
We don't have that.
We have names.
Each one has a
story and it's real.
My coffee has the
least possible acid.
My coffee is stronger
than espresso.
But like I said, there's
business for everybody.
God bless them all.
And I run my business in
10-- like in that Bible,
there's 10 commandments.
I have 10 steps that I follow.
And all my team in my
company, in our company--
or our fraternity, I call
it-- they have that symptoms.
And they follow.
The first one we must have
faith, love, and truth.
And if you have a
business, you run it
in faith, love, and
truth, you have customers.
Customers become your clientele.
Number four, you must respect
them and treasure them.
And that's [INAUDIBLE]
telling me wow, this is great.
Because of my team members and
the quality of my clientele,
number six is telling
me go and grow.
Go open here.
Go open in my district,
open in my city.
And that's what happened.
So number six is I took action.
I act.
Number seven, I organize.
Number eight, I said
we need managers.
It doesn't mean I get
recommended by someone
and he said, oh, Phil, that's
a good manager in Whole Foods,
why didn't you give him a job.
No.
Managers is to me is when I
hire people from the basement
and they're working with me.
And I see them as
doing great job.
They conduct, they have
love, they are filled.
They're not shy.
They're relaxed.
They're focused.
they get up with good
thoughts, good mind.
Do good that day,
you can't go wrong.
If I see that, that guy deserves
to be the supervisor, shift
leaders, or a manager.
And of course I'm
going to pay him more.
Because manager is big name
and he wants more money.
So I have that already
planned for him.
So I have my team
members growing with me.
And we have excellent
people working for us.
And the key is I trust them.
I go to sleep like a baby.
And don't even think twice.
And if once in a while we have a
complaint-- because my business
is like marriage.
It's not perfect.
[LAUGHTER]
But I want to tell
you something.
My house marriage
is in the high 90s.
And my business, in the
real high, high 90s.
Because we not shy
from each other.
We communicate.
We talk.
None of them, I walk
in, or the CEO walk in,
or Carolyn walk in,
or Faith walk in,
or Greg walk in--
oh my god, they
here, what they have
under their sleeve.
What they have up
their shoulder,
you know what I'm saying.
We have none of that.
We walk in, hi Phil, hi Carolyn.
You know?
It's a great feeling.
And I love what I do.
I don't forget
where I came from.
I put 200-300 miles
in my car every day,
I visit four-five
shops to see how can we
become better
tomorrow and do what
we do best, become excellent.
Because people change,
companies change.
But I want to guarantee
you, take this to the bank,
Philz Coffee tomorrow become
better at what we do best.
And maybe we in it for life.
We have love and passion for it.
And we here to grow.
Let's all grow together.
And there is nothing I can't
do for my city, my counties.
Every shop I go to,
that community, I
fit that community.
I hire people from
that community.
And we raise revenue, there's
taxes, put people to work,
less employment.
We give them health,
we give them dental,
we give them vision.
I give them 401(k), I
give him opportunity
to invest in Philz Coffee.
And it's delicious.
I can't explain to
you how good it is.
So I could talk for a year.
[LAUGHTER]
I want to hand it to
Carolyn, thank you so much.
[APPLAUSE]
CAROLYN FREY: Thank you, Phil.
I think it'd be great to get a
show of hands of how many Philz
fans we have in the room.
Wow.
So you'll probably give us some
good feedback across today.
We want to save a lot of time
for questions and answers.
And you all were great
about submitting questions
in advance.
So what we want to do, one
of our biggest challenges
growing Philz coffee
in such a pure mission
is to bring on the right people
and to train them effectively.
So we got a lot of questions
specific to our barista
training, barista, we
like to call them artists.
We actually have some
of our team members
here in the front row.
They may be called
on to ask questions.
But what we thought
is Faith could
talk a little bit about
how we structure training.
What does that
look like at Philz?
And then we'll open
it up for questions.
And hopefully, we'll
address everything
that was submitted in advance.
FAITH SONGCO: So
thankful to be here.
And excited to hear
your questions.
I started at Philz
in April of 2015,
so a little over a year ago.
And it was six months
of finding out,
aren't you a small
mom and pop shop?
And you want to
open a university?
And what does that mean?
And are you really
committed to investing
in your people in the way that
Jacob, when I'd spoken with him
had communicated with me.
And so after talking with
him, and meeting the team,
and going to several shops--
Ferry Street, Middlefield
in Palo Alto, which
is my favorite store,
Cupertino, because obviously I
used to work for a tech company
near there-- visited all
the stores and I said, wow,
is this for real?
Every single store,
whether in San Francisco
or in Sausalito or in
Cupertino felt the same
even though they were
drastically different in look.
And so I was really
intrigued about well,
is it in the hiring?
Or is it in the training?
Or what is it?
Like why are Philz people
so special and so kind?
And a lot of it has to do with
the people be hire, for sure.
Hands down.
There's definitely
a set of things
we look for which makes
training a lot easier.
And it's really, really unique.
And the types of
questions I think
we've been asking folks and
experiences for them to share
with us, I think one of my
favorite things that Phil says
is interviews are
a chance for you
to look at people in the eye and
really understand who they are.
And so when we bring
these people on,
they go through a 15-day
training, or on boarding,
or orientation, however
you want to say it.
But a lot of the
training is not formal.
A lot of it really has
to do with being immersed
and-- I'm seeing nodding
heads here from our baristas.
And so they can vouch for me.
And a lot of it is just being
behind bar with your team.
And in my job, we
have to figure out
what are the parts that
we engineer and design.
And what are the
parts that you don't
want to engineer and
design away, right?
And I remember thinking, gosh,
like, there's so much happening
behind the bar and
there's so much
happening with this customer.
But so much of it has to do
more with that person and how
they connect, and less about the
structure of how we do things.
However, there's a very specific
way we do things at Philz.
Every cup of coffee you have
is personalized to your taste.
Which means you have to
really know and understand
what a person wants.
And you need to be able to
deliver it physically, right,
behind bar.
So it's a great two
week experience.
A lot of it has to do
with the relationship
you build behind bar.
I would say another really
unique thing about training
is it levels the playing field.
I am Leslie Knope, I
am a perfectionist.
And when I got behind
bar I said this is hard.
This is really, really
hard work in the sense of,
like, you really care about
crafting something back there.
But at the same time, you
remember that in the end,
people are here because
they want to see you.
And they want to have
something delicious.
And they want to treat
themselves, right?
So its a really
interesting mix between I
guess your left brain
and your right brain,
between your heart
and your science.
And then ultimately,
the help behind the bar
is that's trading.
Being vulnerable and
level setting of I
don't know how to
do this, I don't
know how to make this
h-- how can you help me?
I think the team that
I trained with really
helped me out that week.
And so now as people go
through Philz University,
I stop by, I say hi.
I say what day are you on?
Because I can tell by where
they are in their training.
And I tell them, if it wasn't
for the team standing next
to me, I wouldn't
know as much as I did.
So a lot of really
interesting things
that actually began
with the training
even before I got there.
I just have the luxury of really
understanding what that is
and making sure that we hold
to it no matter how big we get.
[APPLAUSE]
CAROLYN FREY: So maybe
we'll turn it over
to the audience for questions?
PHIL JABER: [INAUDIBLE]
CAROLYN FREY: Sure, yeah.
PHIL JABER: She said everything
that I needed to say.
But the training came in--
when we started doing it,
Jacob was going to college.
And the first day he
came to me, he said dad,
I'm not going to go to college.
I said uh-oh, getting
in trouble now.
Your mom.
You have two sisters, they
were educated, one is a doctor,
one double business major.
Jacob, go talk to your
mother, don't talk to me.
It took three months for the
family to agree with him.
He came to me.
But Jacob was well-trained when
he was four or five years old.
I used to take him with me.
I used to put a
milk box for him.
And he was working in the cash.
And he was approaching
the customer
like he's 20, 25 years old.
Hi ma'am, how are you?
Anything else?
Even take them back to the car.
And he used to look
straight in the eye to them
and say thank you.
So he was well-trained.
So when we decide to
open more and he agreed,
our family, to work
with me, I said Jacob,
we're going to open shops.
He goes to me.
Then I asked him, I said what
do you want out of Philz.
You want to work, sweep
and mop, $6 an hour?
He goes no, dad.
I said what do you want?
He said I want to grow.
See, grow.
What does that mean?
He said like you trained me.
You could go pick up
shops, open them up.
I will train the people
the way you train them.
And we open one, the
second, and third.
As we opened shops, I
already have team for you
already trained to go to work
tomorrow in case you open.
And that's what happened.
So we had the training
well-trained before.
So to work for me, I look
for three things in a person.
The basics, the value, morals.
He loves to work for
Philz, he loves coffee.
He wants to work, he want
a job, go somewhere else.
So when I meet
them for training,
I used to tell them my name
is Phil, what's your name?
Mr X, I want you to be calm,
settled, relaxed, focused,
be flexible.
Don't be shy for me because you
have something I want from you.
And I'm willing to train you.
So when I ask you a
question, be honest with me.
Because if I find out two, three
months later, the door is open.
You leave by yourself.
So we hire, you fire yourself.
So we have a concept.
So from day one, as we grow on.
And as we grow, we
hire these fine ladies.
And they know what we need.
And Jacob knows what I want.
Sometimes I don't bother,
I don't interfere.
I go sit in meetings
sometimes, just sit and watch.
So our job is
well-trained from day one.
And like I said, tomorrow,
next week, next month,
we become better at what we do.
We simplify things.
And you have to be
humble about it.
You have to be
humble in business.
And the key to success
is greed is disaster.
Satisfy is success.
That's what we aim
to and we're going
to become better than
[INAUDIBLE] than best to come.
That's all I know.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE 1: Hi.
Thank you for coming.
We really-- this is,
like, the most people
I've ever seen in
comic-con before.
So it's quite impressive.
Sort of a silly
question, are there
any plans to sell the infamous
orange cup in Philz locations.
I have a million people who
would purchase about a thousand
of them.
The infamous orange cup.
CAROLYN FREY: So I
can answer that one.
No plans as of now.
We're always open to
ideas and feedback.
So don't be shy about
sending them along.
So we'll take that back.
I think one of the key
principles of how we operate
is never lose sight of the core.
So merchandise is important.
We want folks wearing
Philz t-shirts.
But really, we've got
a lot on our plates.
And it is very easy
to get distracted.
So I think my answer
would be maybe.
But right now, we
have so much work
to do to deliver our
mission, which is looking you
in the eye every day, and
delivering you exactly what you
want, and making you feel great
so you can go off and solve
the world's problems.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE 2: I am a huge fan.
You've actually
ruined coffee for me
because now I can't
go anywhere else.
My question to you is you said
every coffee made has a story.
My favorite coffee
is Philtered Soul.
Which is the story
behind Philtered Soul.
PHIL JABER: I got a
big soul for coffee.
[LAUGHTER]
Philtered Soul because this is
Phil, and I used that filtered.
And everything comes--
[LAUGHTER]
Philtered Soul, I made it like
a dessert, afternoon dessert.
Like after dinner, you want a
piece of cake or cheesecake.
So I made for like
a dessert drink.
But it's a good drink.
Especially if you mix
it with honey and cream.
It's a very satisfied drink.
So Philtered Soul is like
you when you have life,
you have soul.
AUDIENCE 3: I first
started drinking
Philz Coffee in Berkeley.
My favorite blend is Tesora.
I had a question, you mentioned
that greed is disaster.
Over the past decade, many small
business owners in the Mission,
in San Francisco as a whole,
have struggled monetarily.
Many have been forced
to sell their shops
and leave their homes.
How do you start a
successful business yourself
in the mission?
What is your advice to
small business owners
in light of these changes?
How can they be successful?
See in business, you
can't be relaxed.
You can't sit behind the
console, talk on the phone,
watching TV.
You have to stand
erected to God.
Have a smile, greet
the clientele,
have the right
products for them.
Display, feature it
right, reasonable price.
They all need help these days.
Because a lot of people
are losing businesses.
Because first and foremost,
their leases is out.
Landlords wants more money.
And they can't
afford the new rent.
So they leave.
Or they have businesses and
they teach people one or two--
not the right way, they go
outside, they give names.
One become 10, 10 become
20, they stop going there.
You have to be alert.
Courtesy.
And treat people right.
And there's a lot of
big issues these days
with landlords and leases.
They're not satisfied,
they're greedy.
I just cannot understand.
In the 80's, 70's,
80's, families
used to come and rent homes.
And after a while, young
generation, single,
they come to rent.
Share.
Then all of a sudden, people
rent four bedroom house
or three bedroom house and
they share with their friends
so they could afford
to pay the rent.
I just wonder how
they could afford
the one-bedroom apartment in
the Mission for $4,200 a month.
And the kitchen is like 1960.
So that's what we
have in these days.
Either too much wealth up
there from young generation.
Either they earn it from
grandparents or parents,
pass away, left it for
them and they have so much.
They have no conscience.
I don't know who they're
trying to impress.
But we have issue
in that department.
And I don't know.
This is me personally I went
through four-five cycles of up
and down.
I see the next cycle is
going to be the worst we ever
had in our life history.
Because our young
generation don't know
how to struggle to sacrifice.
And I see that coming.
Society change.
Cycle change, business change.
Numbers change.
You know, long time ago,
$40,000 was lot of money.
Now it's like $0.05.
All businesses must pay
attention to their customers.
I see a lot of big
companies like Macy's, GAP,
all these closing.
I don't know why.
But something's happening.
Because maybe Amazon
has taken over.
Go ahead.
CAROLYN FREY: I think
just to add to that.
I mean, we don't take a single
relationship for granted.
And our relationship with our
customers and team members
is our focus.
But Phil really leads
the way in carrying that
through how we do business.
And yes, you could argue we're
growing to a bigger company.
And we're not the small
corner store in the Mission.
But one of the things I think
that's so unique that still
happens is Phil and his son
Jacob meet every landlord
that we do business with.
And that goes through to
every single partner we
have at Philz to our
outside investments,
to a vendor that provides,
helps us with napkins.
That we look them in
the eye and we really
understand who
they are as people.
And do they align
with our values.
And I think that's one of
the unique things I would say
and the advice I'd give
to other businesses,
is focus on what's important.
And make sure you have
those relationships.
You understand.
Because when times
get tough, those
are the things that are
going to carry you through.
PHIL JABER: One more thing.
Like you saying, lot of
people closing, landlord,
leases stuff like that.
Businesses take
care of business.
What happened to us is
every shop that I get either
through a broker or
developer or real estate,
I must meet the owner.
If I don't meet
the owner, no deal.
So I meet the owners,
if we come eye
to eye-- that's why I told you,
business the old fashioned way
is the best-- if
we meet eye to eye,
we understand each other,
whatever we do for each other,
we can't go wrong.
And a handshake, sometimes
I twist my mustache
like my grandpa.
This is my contract.
But I make sure my
daughter, tomorrow-- she
is the master agent for me.
Besise we have real estate,
[? VIB, ?] she'll send him LOI.
The American way, we do
business the American way.
And let's say my option is off.
Which is I have many
shops, options, expired.
Phone call is done.
We didn't have to
go see lawyers.
Spend more money.
So the key is we
must meet owners.
Because it's like marriage.
I want to be with you for life.
We write leases, options.
But in the meantime,
he knows me and him,
we're going to be
cemented for life.
Because when I go to a
special place, open a shop,
God bless what he had.
There's many people
like him own buildings,
have money, developers.
But I tell him, there's
only one Philz Coffee.
And you can't buy that twice.
So when I come to your
building, I'll put in the map,
I desire people to come
to shop for my corner,
I enhance all of the
businesses around me.
Because I don't sell
salads, sandwiches, food.
People-- coffee--
they want salad,
they go across the street.
Slice of pizza, whatever.
So I enhance all the businesses.
Plus I raise his property value.
And I have over 37--
no, maybe 33 landlords,
some of them I have a couple
buildings with, they call me
brother Phil, which
building you like,
I go buy for you to open shop.
I'm serious.
That's what happened to us.
I went to Austin, Texas.
I just came back last week.
We saw 10 locations.
One location I like where
Google companies go in them.
High rise building.
I told them, I want
the bottom shop.
I want to be in Google building.
You see.
I met the owner and
we like each other.
So that's how things work.
Do the right thing.
Be straight and honest.
All my landlords love us.
So I don't know about
other businesses,
how they treat their landlords.
I never call them,
I have problems.
Landlords like that.
So we are flower clientele.
No weeds.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE 4: Phil, how do
you think about expansion?
Your son said
aspirations may lead
to several thousand stores.
Do you expect it to
happen in the next year?
In the next 20 years?
And what challenge do you
foresee to get you there?
Is it high rent prices?
Or other factors?
CAROLYN FREY: I'll take
the first stab at that
and we'll see-- we'll
compare answers with Phil.
I mean, I think, again, think
about our mission, which
is authenticity, quality.
And it's pretty
easy for companies
to go out there and
open 1,000 stores.
There are a lot of
companies in our history
that have done that.
What's most important
to us is to do it right.
And to be welcomed by the
community that we're in.
We're creating community.
Our mission is warmth
and connection.
So we don't want to ever impose
ourselves on a community.
And we want to do it--
so it comes down to one--
a real estate.
We want the right real
estate, the right location,
the right community that
we're going to be successful.
We feel like for a reasonable
degree of likelihood,
we can hire amazing
team members.
And that we can do
it the right way.
And so for us today, that's
been one store at a time.
One customer at a time.
One market at a time.
And I think as we get
better at that, we
will start to accelerate.
And our vision is 1,000 stores.
I don't think we'll get
there in the next five years.
But we could.
It all is kind of
contingent on do
we find the right people
in the right places.
And are we welcome
by that community?
Because we never
want to-- we never
want to overstep and
start to feel like,
oh, we're that corporate company
imposing Philz on communities.
PHIL JABER: You see,
ask me-- our shop,
one shop is like 1,000 shops.
That's how we treat our shops.
I would open everywhere.
Because one time
a guy said Phil,
why you going to Washington DC?
Different market, different
animals, different people.
I said I don't know until I
go take a visit, my friend.
He said why you like Washington?
I said because it's
small like San Francisco.
Six miles by six miles.
OK?
Let me go find out and compare.
So we flew.
We look at locations.
Second day, I sign two leases.
And I get up in the
morning, 4:00, 5:00 o'clock.
I walk two blocks.
There's any shops open, I
walk and see how they talk,
how they conduct.
See, anywhere I go, I'm relaxed.
I fear no one.
I no go, look around,
oh, this is not my city.
I feel like it's my
city anywhere I go.
So I walk around like a
zigzag, see the merchant.
8:00, 9:00 o'clock, I go
back to that location.
And I look up, I see
God looking over me.
I said this is the
place I'm going to get.
So let's move down.
So I got two places.
So I came back.
Two weeks later, my
friend called me up,
he said oh, what
happened to Washington?
I said I signed two
leases, ready to open.
He said I told you
it's different.
I said there's no
different, my friend.
People sleep, eat,
work, go out, enjoy.
Same thing as here, my friend.
Even, you know what?
The smartest people in the
world work in Washington.
They're running the world.
So I opened two shops.
I find out Philz Coffee could
go anywhere in the planet.
Open even in the
mountain, camping.
Build a tent.
People will come
camping for the weekend.
So the only reason I find out
is I could go anywhere, it's
all about destination.
And everything is
[? shifted ?] in this country.
There's no different.
So we're going to open shops.
Next year, maybe
a few, six more?
Next year, maybe 15 to 20?
We're not hurried.
We're still young,
we're still babies.
We're not going nowhere.
Like I told you, music is
for life, coffee is for life.
So like Carolyn said, we
hire the finest people
who have basics,
values, morals, respect.
They love to work.
I like their knowledge, but
they have to follow our concept.
Because I'm completely different
than anybody in this planet.
I'll make it easier for you.
I spent 25 years.
People spend 10 years,
12 years, colleges.
I spent 25 years.
We have it all written down
for hundred years from now.
I have vision, I
have the plan here.
I drew it in my head,
how it's going to be.
And it's working.
It's working because I have
a good, excellent team.
People, culture.
And like I said,
doesn't get hard.
It gets easy for us.
Hard for somebody else.
We are simplifying things.
And things, if it
work, we don't change.
But we are humble.
We like to listen
to people opinion.
And we go back to our
mind, we make decision.
And good people.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE 5: Thank you
guys for coming today.
I had two supply
chain questions.
So the first is Philz used to
be a big favorite here at Google
in our local micro kitchens.
And I guess we no
longer stock Philz
because we don't have a ton of
insight into the supply chain.
So I was wondering
between Google and Philz,
is there a way that we
could bridge that gap?
PHIL JABER: Oh, you could do
that yesterday, my friend.
No problem.
AUDIENCE 5: I can't.
I can't.
PHIL JABER: But
you see, maybe they
changed the marketing
guy, or the food guy,
or the guy who buys
things, maybe he
has [? friends ?] other places.
We don't deal like this.
We deal quality, service.
I want to be cemented
with you for life.
I'm not after money.
I want to give you quality.
When you drink
that cup of coffee,
put a smile in your face.
You might take another one
to your office for later on.
So if you could
make it happen, I'd
like to have a coffee
shop right here.
AUDIENCE 5: Sounds great.
PHIL JABER: I don't need much.
CAROLYN FREY: Yeah,
Greg [INAUDIBLE]
who runs our wholesale
business is here.
He just had his first child, so
he's a little sleep deprived.
But wanted to be here.
And partly-- I mean-- I don't
know the reasons behind it,
but that's one of the things
we're actively working on.
Because we're a company
of transparency.
And so our relationship
all the way back
to the farmer and that
coffee bean is so important.
So I feel pretty confident
without knowing the details
that we've probably come a long
way since that conversation.
And I think if
anyone in this room
can help us bridge that
gap, we are all ears.
AUDIENCE 5: You know is there
anybody here from the food
team that could talk to Greg?
[LAUGHTER]
CAROLYN FREY: Greg.
Greg!
GREG AHLBACH: Yeah, we
always kind of view business
as a conversation.
And would love to open
up that conversation.
The thing about our blends
is they're a family secret.
The people that are
roasting the coffee
know what they're sourcing.
But the people
blending the coffee
don't The only two people
that know are Phil and Jacob.
But with that being that we
want to have a conversation,
we can discuss some stuff.
And find out kind
of a happy medium.
But we would love to
work with you again.
I mean it was a pleasure working
with you for three plus years,
I think it was.
And it was very sad
for us to see you go.
And we highly value our
relationship with you.
So let's talk.
AUDIENCE 5: Yeah.
And my second question
was how many people
know the secret sauce.
[LAUGHTER]
CAROLYN FREY: Yeah, I think
just to drill into that.
I mean, our blend's our secret.
And so we have an entire
supply chain operation,
our roasting plant's in Oakland.
And we have half a team
that knows half the recipe.
And we know another half of the
team that knows the other half.
And this guy here and his son,
Jacob are the only two people--
and there's a lot of ways that
food engineers and scientists
could probably reverse engineer.
But part of it is it's
culture, it's trust.
That's the mystique and
the beauty of Philz.
So it's just-- and we call that
working in the curtain method.
And it adds quite a
bit of complexity,
but our team values it.
AUDIENCE 6: When you first
started the coffee shop back
in '03, what kind of challenges
were you facing when you
started this up in the Mission?
PHIL JABER: No challenge.
Because I've been there for
35 years, I build the name.
You see, I chose San Francisco
when I was 13 years old.
Because seven miles
by seven miles.
If you do business the
right way in the community,
you become a community guy.
You help out with so little
we have-- I have a good name,
reputation.
And during that time, I
was working on coffee.
So when I conquered
my reputation,
I said now I'm going
to do my coffee.
See, it's not--
to own a business,
you have to be a good man,
a family man, honest man.
We're recommended under
good term, good report
from the community, the people.
And the city is small.
So my name was all over.
Like perfume, Joe Malone.
[LAUGHTER]
I have no challenges.
I am my own-- I am
my own competition.
I have no competition.
I no pay attention to
other coffee businesses,
people they have coffee shops.
But I tell you, all
these business people,
they wish to capture clientele
like us, like you guys.
They having a hard time.
So mine comes from you guys.
Because you guys give us name.
You guys, you all
have class and taste,
you know where the quality is.
And not I'm telling you
this just to say it.
It's for sure.
We have quality.
And my beans, I
used to count them
like a pharmacy, one at a time.
I spent lot of years on that.
So we different, how
we run our business,
by culture, the people.
Make your day a better day,
put a smile in your face
as you walking out from
my shop or go sit in my--
I was the first guy to
put community table.
Because this young
generation when
they move to the city
they share rooms,
they have no community table.
They share bathrooms, showers.
So Philz Coffee become
your community tables.
I have so many people met and
they get married in my shops.
That the first time in
the history of the US
ever happened.
That's something to be proud of.
That's mean you
have something good.
And we in it for life.
Best to come.
So I'm talking about Google.
You guys were my first customers
when I open in Middlefield.
I used to deliver
the [? brothers ?]
to the warehouse-- what's the
other building, a little bit
closer north?
Mountain View.
I used to deliver
to the warehouse,
they used to have eight
different companies.
All of a sudden only three.
And what happened between us
and you, it's not from our side.
It's from your leadership.
Or all you need to
do now, all of you,
send an email to the
master, and tel them
what you have done to us.
Bring Philz Coffee back.
[LAUGHTER]
PRESENTER 1: Thank
you, thank you again.
Let's give another
round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]